welcome to another wonderful episode of
the corridor cast
today's guest is Richard Ryan he's an
all-around magnificent person you may
know him from his YouTube channel full
mag or from the black rifle coffee
company or as a wing suitor or halo
jumper or sky diver if you're into that
sort of thing he's a he's a modern-day
Renaissance man he knows about
everything from YouTube analytics all
the way through to what it's like to
almost jump out of an airplane while
you're passed out to what it's like to
start a coffee company and well and work
with a bunch of guys to grow that from
the ground up so litter the ground up
did you catch that okay anyway we'll get
to that in just a second but first I
wanted to tell you about today's sponsor
Sam Gorski that's right he decided to
write this book top 10 games you can
play in your head by yourself
along with our friend David Lovett or
were they the editors I don't know but
either way the books available now just
go to our website corridor digital comm
there's a link to it right there it's
available it's a real thing Richard
thanks for being here mance for coming
to town thanks for having me yeah so you
just had a lot of time freed up in your
schedule
yeah yeah right what were you supposed
to be doing um I probably shouldn't say
her name but we were filming a piece on
a halo jumpmaster
out and Lake Elsinore yeah and Air Force
was getting a little bit weird about us
filming on her because she's kind of the
face of the recruiting campaign so you
you run a really fine line as a
for-profit company and what you can and
can't do with the military because then
it shows kind of like an endorsement
right so is she in the military she is
she's in the reserves right now he's a
badass she's like one of the few halo
jump masters ever so what exactly is a
jump master well it's essentially the
instructor who's training these these
people for Halo certification chomps
what is halo mean
altitude low opening that means your
parachute opens at a low altitude
correct correct solo I'm cutting my
altitude yeah so okay so high altitude
would technically you're supposed to not
exactly sure I think you're supposed to
have oxygen over 16,000 feet and it may
be 14,000 feet somewhere around there
you start thinking about things like
Mount Everest where it's like 32,000
feet or something along those lines
commercial airliners fly around 35,000
feet yeah it becomes really necessary
around 24,000 25,000 feet okay I did a
couple of halo jumps here when a few
years ago and went hypoxic and one of
them and it's a pretty serious ordeal
what does that mean it's oxygen
deprivation so it's I have one of these
really weird kind of attributes where
I'm somewhat of a light sleeper but I
think it's a byproduct of being or
whenever I was younger I used to sleep
in a lot and I'd be worried that my mom
would like come in and she'd like she'd
be like Richard it's time for school and
immediately I would just like a pop up
yeah yeah I'm good I'm ready to go and
like I was just came out of being asleep
so it's like I have this thing
pre-programmed in my head where it's
like oh I just wake up and tell people
exactly what it is that they want to
hear so I'm like maybe sleeping a little
bit consciously
and so the jumpmaster I guess my my Oh
to system wasn't giving me enough oxygen
or whatever so he's he like hit me on my
leg and he's like ready to exit and I'm
like and I'm out I'm unconscious and
like say you look on the cameras and
everything's like okay I can see where
he thinks that I'm you guys like pop on
my leg and then I'm like thumbs up and
I'm out and so he goes and like pushes
me like it's not a plane no no inside
the plane yeah yeah yeah I mean I would
have woke up at about probably 15,000
feet if I wasn't in a flat spin or
something like that but yeah but that's
scary yeah yeah yeah it's a part of the
job I guess yeah it's it's it's it's a
real deal for sure so so the jump
kiboshed I guess just this one was that
one okay I see I went back down to the
ground and everything was good okay we
did some medical tests and everything
and I'm I was good to go back up later
on that afternoon nice was that reason
since you've been here no that was
probably 20 I wanna say 2014 2015 okay
something like that so what got you into
jumping out of airplanes relativity
media actually for active aller they
were they were like hey look we won't we
really like you we want you to do
something to promote the film can you
guys give us a pitch deck of things that
you could do I was like I'll do this on
breaching with c4 plastic RDX explosives
det cord whatever yeah I'll do something
on drones and I'll do something on Halo
jobs or whatever like yeah oh that's
good do mall like what what know which
one and they're like no all of them all
of them okay cool I guess I got to learn
how to skydive so that was like uh that
was a pretty pretty surreal moment
because I never really wanted to skydive
right there was just something that
never I'm terrified of heights and
things along those lines so one of my
good friends Dave was like oh no I want
you like what you learn just got off
because I won't want to Scott I have and
everything and it like so if I didn't
have him going with me
like at the same time pushing me I
probably wouldn't stuck with it but I'm
pretty analytical about risk versus
reward on certain things so I had to get
in there and I had to start looking at
statistics how many people have died and
like what are the injuries associated
with it and everything it's actually
kind of interesting like the the
statistics that you hear people quote
versus like what you know what causation
versus correlation and things along
those lines actually dictates certain
things or whatnot and yeah so was
interesting was looking at how many
people died skydiving then they
encompass everything from people in high
performance canopy maneuvers you know
swooping and things along those lines to
everyone doing tandem jumps and things
along those lines it was like oh yeah so
the the person who's strapped to an
instructor is in the same category as
somebody who's competing at the highest
of the level in a very very very small
canopy going straight at the ground
right so
after I saw that stuff and how few
people were actually injured under
student canopies and things along those
lines it's okay I can give it a shot for
sure and then once I got into it after
like six or seven jobs I was like oh wow
this isn't even bad at all because
there's a forward speed on the aircraft
and when you exit you don't get that
feeling of falling they call it the hill
where you're essentially just sliding
down a slide even though you are exiting
the airplane that forwards B keeps that
sensation of falling from happening and
then you're kind of really just looking
at Google Maps and 120 mile per hour
winds whatever I mean so like your your
brain really can't make it all out like
you did like I if I look at a two-story
three-story building over the edge from
the roof or whatever like here I'm like
the edge you know or whatever put them
from an airplane it's like okay whatever
like relative perspective is just really
isn't there so Wow yeah so when did you
start doing high-altitude jumps that was
probably 2013 or 2014 what what's the
difference I guess between a regular old
just jump and that yeah I mean that will
though the consequences are greater
especially because you're dealing with
so many different variables you're
adding different things to the equation
with your equipment so normally you just
have like you're you're skydiving red
your helmet and everything else will now
you're you're bringing in an oxygen tank
and oxygen masks you know are you
getting a good seal around your face and
things along those lines that you need
to be clean-shaven a lot of different
things there but then the depending on
the altitude that's where the the
consequences go up for the greater you
the the greater the height you go 24,000
feet it's not nearly as risky as 30 from
35,000 feet way riskier than 30 because
I mean it's essentially a dead zone
right because you how many people you
hear going up to Everest and and dying
all in the way and there's just bodies
littering the the path to the summit and
people just don't have the the gas to
get them off of the mountain and things
along those lines so you're essentially
higher than that if you break the seal
you're not going to get enough oxygen to
be able to sustain
consciousness really yeah that's and so
that's the risk as you could pass out
yeah and then not have enough oxygen in
your brain to survive yeah well flying
through the air in this guy when that
happening yeah yeah yeah that's a risk
it's a risk
kind of incredible though that like of I
guess of all the jump masters who are I
guess training for this you know it's
like there's two you said well I don't
know yeah I don't know the the exam or
the exact number
you probably count on your hand how many
female jump masters or halo jump that I
see and she's one of them she's just a
phenomenal chick she's awesome what you
were filming so you're working in you're
shooting it what were you shooting where
you're shooting like an independent or
you came here to shoot an independent
thing or is this something with the
Earthforce or like what was what's that
like yeah so so I'm one of the owners in
black rifle coffee and so back in the
day when we we first started it we were
looking at you know the different
different ways to grow the company and
and early on Matt and Matt best and my
channels like had significant YouTube
followings yeah his Facebook and whatnot
so we relied heavily on that organic
reach and a lot of the content that we
did was very much shock and awe you know
the stuff that I do blowing things up
him when his walkthroughs and whatnot so
whenever I left rated red to focus on
black rifle coffee full-time what I
really wanted to do was kind of add more
depth to the brand and the stories that
we tell so we still have the
entertainment based stuff that the humor
driven content but I wanted to add some
type of inspirational quality to it that
you know I have so many cool people in
my life people who work for us people
who are friends at the company and
things along those lines that have
amazing stories and so now we have a
platform to tell it I just wanted to
take it as an opportunity especially
with the you know it's a black rifle
Coffee has more of a I would say a
veteran defined like you know every way
voice and so a lot of the stories we try
to tell her the veterans within our
community and and people who may still
be serving and so Tiffany's just been a
a good friend of a lot of my partners
and whatnot so wanted to sell her story
we had Sean Evangelista as a former
DEVGRU guy he is in Sun Valley ski
patrol went up there and told his story
along with some of the other guys in the
company so she's really trying to tell
in you know five to ten minutes try to
do these guys justice and you know what
it is their story or what their story is
and then the transitioning process that
they went through from government
service and disability in life I see
yeah and I I mean like of all them like
the top guys a black rifle coffee are
you the only one who hasn't actually
like actively served correct how does
that feel working with them because of
that it's not like it's a chip on the
shoulder or anything like that we do we
know that you know just they're not
always like no genuine role absolutely
you better believe that so we did it we
did a video we did a video for Halloween
and it's it's hilarious it's like if
veterans were in horror movies or
something along those lines it's not
match Channel and it's like like all my
partner's coming in you know into the
house for this Halloween video and it's
like Evan hey for Army Special Forces
you know like you know Army veteran Matt
best like you know Army Ranger like or
be veteran and then JT like Air Force
better that's like Richard crying
YouTube veteran it's it's it's it's it's
it's funny like it really doesn't bother
me we joke around back and forth and
everything but it's it's a lot of fun
yeah aren't those guys cable jumping
though no so I don't know if anyone I
know Evan had I think he had his free
fall certification but none of them have
their licenses and that's something we
were gonna try to work on format this
year was to get his license and
everything but yeah I mean thank you not
that they're they're afraid of it or
anything it's just there's it's a
significant time commitment yeah it's
not everybody's cup of tea for sure it's
really funny yeah are you still doing
wingsuit Iommi yeah yeah oh is that
going yeah it's going it's going it's uh
you know like
don't want to play like the the little
violin here or anything but you know you
get you get into a very analytical
person and I you you know look at the
statistics and skydiving and things
along those lines and that's what got me
into the sport yeah the ability to
rationalize the risk versus a reward I
got into wingsuiting and like I can
honestly say that there's really nothing
remotely close to it in life for me
right now it's easily one of the most
spiritual most engaging most present
thing that requires me or whatever I
don't know how I put it but there's
there's a really good book that I read
that I actually summed it up really well
and I didn't really know what I was
trying to say to people tell I read the
book it's called stealing fire I forget
who the author is but essentially it
like the stories are great it talks
about like these these guys from you
know these deaf crew guys or Navy SEALs
to professional athletes who are at the
top of their game yeah and essentially
they call it flow state it's a frame of
mind where you're just very present in
the moment you're you're in the zone so
to speak and it talks about you know
them and how they're able to react in a
very natural way that doesn't require
communication but everyone's in tune
with each other and different people
achieve at different ways it talks about
Burning Man and how people do it through
micro dosing hallucinogenic substances
and things along those lines - I forget
this this this chicks name but she's a
believ a skier or snowboarder she was
like you know one of those those big
mountain skiers back in the day and she
wasn't always like chasing these these
really really dangerous lines to be in
the first person to do it and everything
and had so many close calls with death
and she was constantly getting in that
state and she just quit at the top of
her game and a lot of people you know
we're dying you know trying to do the
same stuff and things on those lines and
when she got into yoga and then she said
like after like six months she was able
to achieve that same flow state as you
know whenever
she was at the highest level doing these
things and it's interesting because I
hear guys like Andy stump talk about it
and everything and it's something that
I've kind of had to deal with last few
years probably 2013 2014 was a really
heavy year far as the wingsuit community
was concerned because wingsuiting and
skydive or let me rephrase that wingsuit
skydiving in wingsuit base are two
completely different things
skydiving is in my opinion more
dangerous than wingsuit skydiving
because when you're falling in a group
of say like five people you're
relatively close to each other and then
upon deployment altitude you separate
and you're still relatively close and
the bolt majority of injuries and
fatalities come from canopy related
incidents if it's a parachute
malfunction where they have to cut away
they cut away into somebody who's below
them or canopies collide or the pattern
gets too tight on landing and stuff like
that but when you're wingsuiting you
know at 3,000 feet you just fly away
from each other
you got a glide ratio you can fly a
thousand feet away from somebody before
you've been boy so you just taken that
that that out of the equation
the big injuries and fatalities come
from well more fatalities and injuries
from proximity-based and that's what
most people perceive wingsuit flying as
is flying down this mountains and things
all nose lines BASE jumping dead air
jumps and whatnot and that was a pretty
heavy year like we lost I mean you don't
use it lightly I'd say probably like 20
plus friends or 20 plus acquaintances is
probably two really really good friends
one who was like it really impacted me
in a really like significant way it was
really tough noticed I started flying
extremely conservative which is probably
not the best of things too even from
skydiving perspective you want to you
want to be super in tune you want to
yeah I don't want to say take risk but
you know flying aggressively or flying
more instinctively than conservatively
generally yields better results and so
the last few years and everything it's
just been a it's it's been a thing
psychologically in dealing with and you
know that's one reason why I was really
excited
to get back out here and you see some of
my friends and get a bunch of jump time
and and sign off on my pro rating and
all this other stuff that I'm working on
so Wow yeah see your pro rating yeah
that that's gonna require you that's
gonna allow you to from what I
understand skydive into public
facilities yeah yeah demonstration jump
so I can jump into stadiums or you know
sporting events or like a corridor live
event yeah so you can like just ditch
the uber and basically like land right
in your seat yeah yeah I mean I have to
notify the FAA beforehand but okay
because they have to they have to clear
that air traffic you know depending on
the altitude that I exit and everything
but yeah it's it's exciting that's one
of the things we're looking forward to
this year's doing a few demonstration
jumps with black rifle coffee and
whatnot what's what's like your what's
your goal or the first destination you
want to land in um you know I really
don't know I'll take it as it comes but
I think the the NASCAR race at Texas
Motor Speedway since we have a good
partnership with them is probably gonna
be one of those because JT sang the
national anthem out there last year and
I think we're gonna plan like somewhat
of a big event this year where we'll
have like a drinkin bros podcast out
there we'll have our LM TV out there the
big coffee truck light medium armored
vehicle and we'll jump in me
Andy stomps and Trevor Thompson and have
a have a good ol time out there
that's awesome that'll kick off the race
or what yeah yeah yeah that's sweet man
yeah what's your wing suit look like
what kind of pattern you got on there
well the one I have with me hilariously
enough is toothless from How to Train
Your Dragon it's it's so funny because I
get so many mixed reactions from people
they're like what what and some people
like oh they're so cool that's so cool
because it's like that's honestly like
one of my most like favorite movies
because it it it gets wingsuiting and
skydiving
exactly
exactly right it's like on the nose like
they had some consultants there were
some friends of you know the communities
and whatnot there and I I was working
with 20th Century Fox on a few different
campaigns like Madagascar's penguins and
stuff like that and I had this wingsuit
made just out of spec I was like I want
to do this I want to do how to drink
train your dragon' like brandon video so
like I don't even care if you guys do it
and I want to do dragon racing in real
life and like if we have to get some
like cosplay
Vikings to ride us and like you know
carrying the Sheep and stuff like that I
want to do it I want to do it but they
ended up not going for it because of the
liability reasons and everything's I
don't care I'm still gonna get the
wingsuit right you should do that that
would be a good video yeah a lot of fun
are you still you said at one point I
don't know if you're still doing this
but when you were wingsuiting you were
going for a distant horizontal distance
record or pursue that any closer we did
there was one of those things where I I
feel like a tourist in a lot of ways
because like I've said in the past that
I feel like I'm just living vicariously
through myself and that like I'm I'm
just like everybody else I'm like
watching myself do these things like on
YouTube and and whatnot and I almost
feel like a tourist in a lot of ways
especially some of these these sporting
type activities where you know there's
I've been doing it for eight years but
there's guys who've dedicated you know
their lives and their careers to
wingsuiting and things along those lines
so I felt like it was just kind of a I
don't know as it was just a is it the
barrier for entry for some of those
records is you could you could pay to
get to that point like you yeah you
could get an aircraft to get you that
point so you could break those records
and some people couldn't afford to do
that and if you have sponsors and stuff
like that you arguably could so it was
like I don't really want to be the dude
who just like goes out there and smashes
all these dudes records that you know
like like Jonathan Flores he set a bunch
of records and you know he was a great
innovator in the sport like he was in
product development camera
flying and things along those lines so
he still holds a bunch of those records
and my opinion you just paid he paid his
dues and and things along those lines
like Amy stump you know he got that
horizontal distance record and flew you
know like crazy you know his suit and
and whatnot so is like yeah I don't know
if I really want to pursue that stuff
unless I'm you know working with one of
those dudes too right now just break up
break up ton of Records let's like
collectively go do something fun as a
project versus me doing something solo I
just it feels too selfish yeah no that
makes sense
especially given how small the community
is and how like connected the sport is
my ego does not need any stroke and for
sure Cola is bringing this longest
horizontal jump to you right from 40,000
feet oh yeah yeah exactly
that's exactly right now I get it
so what's it what's it like working with
the other black rifle coffee guys like I
mean I would imagine everyone's kind of
have their their own hobbies and
interests and things like that yeah how
do you guys get started - well yeah so
Matt I don't know if Matt reached out to
me when but you know JT was a sound guy
for me at shot show like ten years ago
really yeah it was it's crazy he was a
sound guy for me and I didn't put two
and two together until Matt and I had
actually met each other and him and JT
we're doing article 15 together and I
don't know if a shot show or what but
it's it's been a few years when he the
way he tells me is that you know he
watched totally sketch and some of the
other stuff that I did while he was
deployed and so that's why he he was
following me on social media and thanks
along those lines and how we could have
gotten in touch with each other and then
I think it was 2014 Evan and the article
15 guys did a sample coffee roasting a
forget what it was called it was like
freedom roast or something like that
yeah and they did it for Christmas I
think it was like 500 bags for article
15 and it did really well and so
Matt JT and I were all talking about you
know what could we do like what's what's
the best way to kind of go about this
whole thing or like well you know
Richard has a large youtube following
that has a really growing fast Facebook
following and things along those lines
you know what can we all just kind of
come together and start this thing
black rifle coffee or whatever and I
think it was in January of 2015 it was
either before or after shot show kind of
inked the deal on the company and Salt
Lake City and then you kind of you know
focus on it for a couple years here and
there and and and then it really started
catching steam and once a 20 2017 yeah
and then in that forced you know the the
the growth really enforced Matt and JT
and everybody to move up from El Paso to
Salt Lake to focus on it full-time and
then I resigned from rated red to come
to Salt Lake to focus on it and then we
kind of relocated to San Antonio here
last year and just keep snowballing and
keep snowballing and it's great I mean
nothing will put stress on a friendship
like a business relationship but it's
it's great I mean it's really it's
really fascinating because you you look
at the you know I I've told a few people
over the years that you know like I
value their friendship too much to go
into business with things along those
lines because it's like like I know like
as soon as you start thinking about
money and things on those lines it
really has a way to strain and stress
things and I found over the years and
the different jobs that I've had in the
different executive roles and whatnot
you know I don't want to say
specifically any names or anything like
that but it was very lonely in a lot of
ways because I didn't really like the
people that I was working with in in
some way shape or form and it just
didn't it didn't click it didn't feel
like those people were my my kind of
people
and you know I I loved Matt Evans JT and
all the people who work for us it's it's
it's really it's really humbling to be
able to go into work and you know you
get caught up in the small details of
the day-to-day we
like man this man we're gonna like we're
not we're not doing enough we're not
doing this and we're not doing that and
you look at how much progress has been
made in the last year the last eight
months the last six months it's crazy it
just blows your mind and I'm like and
then and then you take a step back and
like especially traveling like right now
and everything you you think about like
all the the just that the small things
that they do that we don't technically
like we're not we're not going out there
tweeting about or putting on social
media just they're good people like
really good people and you know I love
them to death I mean it's it's it's it's
it's it's really humbling and it's a
huge honor to have those guys as
business partners for sure yeah well I
also you know I I look at what you guys
are doing and like it seems kind of like
the next best step for what you could
have been doing anyways because
basically you know you there's there's
all that social media presence and you
know you're kind of in a way you're kind
of being able to kind of take that and
do something a lot greater than just
simply try and trade cash for views so
to speak you know it's like it builds a
community in I think a lot more
productive of a way and also what helps
enable you guys to do what you want to
do yeah in in a much more effective way
than just trying to like you know
subsist off of social media so to speak
yeah I agree and you know there's I mean
there's a lot of things to unpack there
the way I like to put it is maybe this
isn't right maybe it is the way I feel
about it is I was at a marketing
conference and I was listening to some
other CMOS you know talk about different
things and one of the guys said
something that really resonated with me
I forget what company he was he was
chief marketing officer for but there's
something like Unilever or Procter &
Gamble or something like one of the
umbrellas that owns Unilever and he was
talking about this guy there that was
buying artisan soap and it was like 15
10 $15 bars or so he's like well you
know we we spin
millions and millions and millions of
dollars on supply chain management
cutting out the middleman we own every
aspect of production and distribution
for the most part outside of ups and
everything else we we make our soaps we
like all the fragrance we do market
research we know exactly what fragrances
you want we're running these advertising
campaigns to you extremely strategic
like to the point knowing when and where
you want them getting the cost down to
next to nothing and yet instead of
buying this 3-pack for three dollars
that is exactly tailored to you you're
buying this $15 bar soap from this guy
why like why are you why are you
spending your money like that and he's
like well you know I don't know if I
love this company but I love the hands
that made it and I feel like with social
media there's a huge disconnect with a
lot of people in society these days are
yearning for some some type of
meaningful connection and I think that
the way that people spend their money is
one really good way to establish that
and that's one reason well the type of
content the way everyone is outside of
the content like if people see us in
person things along those lines
try to try to provide as much value with
everything that it is that we do between
the coffee the subscription services to
the content to just the people in person
and things along those lines and I think
that's what's really resonating what
people you know you see people like you
know Evan and Matt and JT who you know
dedicated their life to the service of
their country and they have I mean
they're badasses
you know I mean they're like they're
they're the most humble badasses you'll
ever meet but they're really really
really really good people like like
their moral compasses or true north I
mean they're just great people and I
think a lot of a lot of people have a
disconnect with the stuff that they're
buying and things along those lines and
they just want that they seem at doing
these these walkthroughs or I mean
blowing this up or doing that and it's
like well I'm going to be a part of that
and I want that in my life in some way
shape or form and I mean that's not to
say that's the only reason I mean we we
make really good coffee right
but it's not a saturated market either
right there's there's not a lot of
people competing for us I mean there's
Starbucks and stuff like that but
there's not a lot of small batch roaster
order companies out there competing with
us in that sense so you know I just feel
like you you know who knows maybe the
economy will shift and people won't have
as much disposable income and then
they'll go back to the Walmart's and
they'll you know it's more about my
family right now or you know like just
being able to pay the bills and not
being able to have extra money to spend
on you know supporting creators or
whatever it is but I really feel that
that that disconnect in society is one
of the driving forces in the success of
a lot of what we do when other people do
not to mention I mean you look at like
everything externally it's like you know
you know we work with a lot of
nonprofits like warriors Heart
Foundation which is rehab facility for
people with you know substance abuse and
things along those lines and that we did
a profile piece on the guy who runs that
facility out there Tom Spooner one of
the board members and he is just an
amazing dude he's just an amazing dude
and you know we're surrounding ourselves
with people who you know are actually
doing doing really really really
meaningful work really good meaningful
work out there and you know I've I'm
guilty of like you know certain times
where you see nonprofit organizations
and stuff like that you're like where's
my money going to like like I want to
support a cause because I want to
believe in something or I want to do you
know I want to help out in some way
shape or form and so being able to vet
these these companies and you know who
we work with and things along those
lines I think a lot of people see it and
they're like yes I want a part of that I
want a part of that so I mean there's
there's a I mean a lot to unpack there
and I know it just kind of went on oh
that's interesting yeah well I mean I
think it makes a lot of sense too
because I feel like people certainly
recognize that kind of anonymizing
factor you get while you're online so to
speak but you know like money money is a
part of you it's a piece of you it's and
it's a commitment to it well you know
you're not going to get back well no so
that's the thing is right so what all
money in my opinion is is it's a
representation of time and times the
commodity that we Trey
right and that's the one thing we'll
never get back mhm and I feel like
people are starting to understand the
value of that and how precious precious
it is so they're being a little bit more
frugal or more strategic and how they
spend it yeah yeah so yeah yeah where
it's like it's almost like you know it's
it's all it's it's the product itself is
only one factor in that equation but
it's also like the source of that
product or the people behind it and etc
etc for sure yeah also I mean looking
right now with how kind of your YouTube
career has been and kind of like the
current state of YouTube I guess in the
sense of it's the some of the some of
the insecurities that are happening
right now I feel like you know that that
mode of business is it's kind of oh I
guess curating and kind of allowing that
community to kind of flourish kind of
almost like outside of YouTube and sense
cuz you guys kind of came you know you
had you you've been on you you're still
on YouTube everyone is yeah but but um
you know they have not sure where I'm
going no I know exactly what you're
saying it allows you to allows you to
generate revenue outside of the YouTube
ecosystem yeah but you're still reliant
on it unfortunately and that's that's
the inherent struggle because yeah you
know you they may take away the D
monetization and you may find a way to
romana ties outside of it but you're
still you know I mean YouTube's the
second largest search engine out there
and and the distribution for content is
just undeniable far as SEO and organic
through subscribers and things along
those lines and it's like I need that I
don't want to have to pay for it every
single time so it's it's really
frustrating because it's like well while
I may be able to make money outside of
the the typical business model which
would probably be ad revenue driven and
then switching it to consumer you know
products or something along those lines
consumables which is absolutely
phenomenal because you know how many
t-shirts can you buy in a year versus
how many things are you gonna eat in a
year so it's it's it's it's a fantastic
business model in some
but you're still beholding to the Beast
in a lot of ways yeah well I think kind
of what I'm thinking here is a little
bit of what we were talking about
earlier with I guess this content you're
creating you know everything from like
the original like rated our our channel
to like the present-day stuff you're
shooting for black rifle and looking at
how YouTube kind of treats that style of
content yeah and by by slapping a D
monetization on anything firearms
related context free it's kind of
alienating an entire kind of group of
people in sense and yeah and kind of
what you're currently doing even though
it's a coffee company kind of like at at
its head it's kind of creating it's kind
of like taking that community that would
be maybe on YouTube and you're creating
a new platform for it you know a
platform for people who are interested
in military or veterans or things like
that it's YouTube is with that stuff is
kind of pushing them away from their
platform mm-hmm with in stating these
rules I wish they were a little bit more
consistent with their Terms of Service
and I just say that you know stemming
off of your statement there in hopes
that I know that a lot of YouTube
content creators and hopefully people
and YouTube listen to this and things
along those lines but the frustration
with me isn't necessarily the type of
content in the the quote unquote
centering censoring that happens is the
inconsistencies with their enforcement
and in certain things so it's like you
know I've been fortunate enough to
manage you know companies worth you know
like like between Verizon and Hearst and
you know all the other movie studios and
ad agencies that I've worked with over
the years millions of dollars and a
marketing marketing money and it's it's
really frustrating to me that that
alphabet has so many properties like
Adwords and YouTube and they'll say hey
look you know what we'll take 5,000
we'll take fifty thousand a hundred
thousand dollars from you to promote
this video and then two weeks later
YouTube will kill it for monetization
it's like so AdWords it can pay to
promote it
so it's okay to run as an ad but then
the second you stop paying to run it as
an ad will kill its organic reach
through search and related videos
because it's not suitable for
advertising which is hilarious to be
because there's so many videos out there
as a brand I would love I would love to
be advertising on y'all's videos I'd
love to be advertising online but then
they get D monetize it's so frustrating
so it's not suitable for advertisement
would you and you're there and you're an
advertiser at seeking to advertising yes
and then that and what's hilarious about
is even like it's not hilarious it's
ironic that they come out short of their
earning statement and I'm over here
screaming saying look I'm I'm I'm like I
have all these other companies that I've
worked with between ad agencies and
studios that are literally begging to
spend millions of dollars and you're
you're just you're inconsistencies and
how you enforce certain Terms of Service
just makes it impossible because nobody
wants to flush money down the drain
yeah and of Facebook you know love or
hate them at least they're way more
consistent with how they enforce their
Terms of Service with advertisers and
content creators you know YouTube is
like it's it's it's it's a blessing and
a curse being so big because I feel like
the the company itself you know we've
we've known so many people over the
years I mean I remember back in the day
you guys remember Eric be the name is
very familiar so yeah I know what I
didn't want to throw his last name out
there but way back in the day like 2010
you can hit him up and be like cuz the
homepage was curated if you like bro I
got I got like I got a video I'll be
working on it's gonna be so good and
then I like send him a Dropbox link or
something like that and let him see a
preview of it and is like oh yeah that's
great I mean you put it on the homepage
like whatever you upload and stuff now
it's like there's certain issues that
I've been trying to get taken care of
like little things like you know like
black rifle coffees adsense acount like
like it's been running ads for like five
years but there's no payment ever been
made
like hey for like a year hey can we get
some help with this and it's in and and
and going through trying to there's no
way to escalate things through YouTube
support and things along those lines and
I'm like like I've gone through like
probably 50 or 60 different email
threads just back and forth back and
forth you know that's how it will pass
this long to sell it so I'm like ah like
how how can anybody afford the time let
alone the bandwidth the and everything
just to be able to get some of these
things done it's the same yeah so what
others you said you guys are running
subscription services of your own like
what yeah what does that entail what are
you doing so so coffee is is a really
fascinating consumable right we're you
you would think to the average person
whenever you you go buy coffee coffees
coffee right well so whenever you roast
it it's not best right when it comes out
of the roaster because depending on the
moisture content or you know the type of
being or whatever it is it requires an
off gassing process to be able to
achieve it's it's its peak flavor
profile now again like flavor is
completely subjective right to each
their own
some people like stuff that tastes like
rubber tires that's over roasted some
people like superlight you know fruity
you know notes or whatever but generally
the off gassing process is a certain
window and then the peak flavor profile
is another certain window when you start
adding in distribution cycles of like
different you know food or beverage
manufacturers and stuff like that by the
time it gets to the store shelves it's
flat now it may not be bad but it's
flattened out the flavor profile and for
us you know we offer a subscription this
isn't a sales pitch it is but it is like
I'm just trying to trying to throw it
out there it's like you know our the
idea with us being small batch roast
orders we have a roasting facility and
Salt Lake in a Nashville right so we
cover the east and the west coast so
whenever you order we roast that and
then we ship it so in that shipping
window it's off gassing to arrive at its
peak flavor profile we also have a
coffee club subscription so it's like oh
I'm gonna usually drink X amount of bags
of coffee I'm
well instead of having to strategically
like figure out what you know that best
window is you just sign up for the copy
club you save money you get free
shipping and then the coffee arrives at
its peak flavor profile you can even mix
it up you can switch up your bags and
stuff like that trial of different
things or do a random bag or whatever
and and then on top of it you know we we
provide we have a lot of really good
close connections with other
manufacturers and brands and stuff like
that provide discounts through their
coffee club subscriptions you know we do
exclusive content kind of like what you
guys do through patreon and and whatnot
so it's like alright we have like our
own kind of little paywall for
entertainment discounts and things along
those lines so the value proposition is
through the roof in my opinion just for
a bag of coffee I mean it's just you can
get a coffee club subscription for one
bag of coffee and you're already saving
on on shipping for the month so it you
know everybody's different you know some
people put a gallon of milk and you know
a half pound of sugar and their coffee
you know will you be able to taste the
difference and you know store-bought
coffee you know that's that's four or
five months old if you're putting that
much cream and sugar in it I don't know
maybe but if you're drinking if you're
drinking black or if you really want to
support you know a good company good
group of dudes and you know all the
great stuff that we do and everything we
feel like the value proposition is just
it's through the roof so I'm a little
bit biased just a little bit biased oh
yeah but I mean it's great like we're
planning on doing some trips this year
we're gonna probably go to Ethiopia and
we're gonna go to Peru and a few other
places and stuff like that I mean I like
coffee was never really one of those
things that I was drawn to Evan you know
he's he's the the man behind all the
stuff he's the driving force and it's
it's been for me I've liked being a
student in general I love learning new
things like you know be it be it in
entertainment media advertising and
marketing life in general like I just
love learning about things I just find
it fascinating him coffee and just
unpacking all the different nuances is
just so
yeah how do you even get say I wanted to
start a coffee company yeah what do I go
do what do I do
well where do I buy coffee call me first
tell me personally to support you guys
no no no no I put you in the red belt
latina to see this is a funny thing
though is it's so funny in that you
early on him my career I was extremely
competitive I think all of us are hyper
competitive you know and look at a lot
of the things that we do and the if
we're racing cards were playing airsoft
or whatever it is hyper hyper hyper
competitive but the the really funny
thing is is you over the last five or
ten years though it's like like I was
talking to Phil DeFranco about this it's
like I'm talking about doing a coffee
with him or something like that
potentially I am so legit excited to see
my friends become successful because I
would much rather you guys just kill the
game in some way shape or form because I
know you're great dudes right where it's
like I'd rather you you achieve some
kind of great success than see some
[ __ ] along the way do it instead so
it's like oh I'd rather I'd rather much
like my friends like yeah I'll be
successful in all their endeavors right
now of course man of course and that's
how we feel and that's I think why we've
always grooved on everything we've done
yeah because we both have that
philosophy but I just mean from like a
logistics standpoint I I try to think
about this just from an outside
perspective and it seems like a
logistical nightmare it is and there's
so so many inherent struggles with so
many different things and that's where
you have to like or I have to give
credit to Evan and Matt the team and
everybody in the company because it's
it's one of those things we're very
fortunate and that you know the content
that we do to opens a lot of doors
because a lot of people appreciate it
and they're like hey like you know you
we love what you're doing if you guys
want to collaborate in some way shape or
form but then you know like on it is
another good example being able to you
know Evan being able to reach out to
Aubrey Marcus or or someone and say hey
I got it this question or being able to
reach out to these other guys and say
hey I got this
question I mean just the network of
people that you meet along the way
becomes invaluable so you can avoid the
pitfalls of certain business choices or
decisions that you know a lot of these
guys have already made in the process so
that's that's that's that's that's no
problem any time any time you have a
question please
so you source it from all over the world
well not right now not right now that's
what we're looking at and again like
there's there's the logistical the costs
and and things along those lines to be
sourcing from Ethiopia and Peru and
whatnot you know Costa Rica and
Guatemala are way closer yeah and you
know it's it's it's just figuring out
those those kind of variables and what
the consumer may want and things along
those lines
right yeah Wow so in making this I guess
I'm gonna call it a switch I'm gonna go
ahead and call it a switch I'm gonna say
you switched from ad-supported content
to product 2 to consumer supported
project you cutting out the middleman
yeah that's I mean you look at it this
way if if you if you are an ad driven
platform and I know I'm probably
preaching to the choir here but we rely
on our CPM or cost per Mille and you
know you say you make a good a good one
would be five dollars so yeah a million
impressions you get five thousand
dollars and I mean a million views
that's a lot that's a lot this day and
age and five thousand really you know
when you're paying the light bill in
rent in LA and insurance like my license
is just my destructive device license is
three thousand dollars and yeah you
start putting in all these permits and
things along those lines it adds up
really quick so it's like if I can get
you know just just you know a fraction
of a percent to convert and on anything
an ink pen
you know like I'm gonna have a dollar
margin on a packet ink pens or something
like that and then you know I sell like
ten thousand of them on a video that got
a million impressions like oh well I
just made $10,000
and I didn't have to be advertiser safe
in some way shape or form er I didn't
have to I didn't have to be scrutinized
I mean you guys if you guys have had to
deal with it in the past like I've had
some some some partners who really like
to go around on those revisions and I
was like just hey I know how to I know
how to speak to people who appreciate my
content let me do it let me do it let me
let me speak authentically to the
viewers well that's that's I think the
biggest that's going to be the biggest
thing for creators trying to do more
than just make videos I think especially
over the next like 5 10 years here as
the economy continues to change
yeah it's you see you're seeing like Gen
4 almost come up onto YouTube and
they're all experiencing the same thing
it's the same thing they happen to us
the same thing that happened to the
people after them it's like well you
know what's great is as a case study
what I'm fine really really fascinating
what I get really really excited about
is I hate the term influencer like I
like I want to throw up every time I
hear somebody say that they're an infant
because everybody's an influencer to
some degree shape right maybe don't 1
how much derogatory it may be one person
it may be to a million people but with
like what's gonna happen as people start
shifting is it's not they're still gonna
be like advertising is is multi billion
dollars interests never never going away
right but we'll start seeing true
influencers like people who may have
been able to do a brand deal for like a
few thousand dollars actually have a
really really rabid strong following be
able to convert really really well I
mean you look it look it uh was it who
is it Kylie Jenner that has the lipstick
yes it's that multi-billion dollar
makeup company billion dollars yeah
with a billion yeah with a beat as I
think her her net worth is is projected
around nine hundred plus which is way
more than any of the other Kardashians
that that's that's that's an influencer
with a product driven influence versus
an ad driven influence yeah I mean
that's I think that's what we're seeing
and I think that's what I mean by these
next generations that are coming up like
the
they're gonna see the same thing I can
mean the first thing that everyone tries
to do and they pick up a camera phone is
shoot a video and try to get it to go
viral yeah and then after that after you
do that for a little while and you
figure it out and you realize oh we're
actually in the grand scheme and things
we're cut and I don't mean this as a
derogatory to people that are struggling
because everyone's getting screwed we're
all eating a [ __ ] sandwich but like yeah
if we should realize how quickly you're
getting screwed you're like oh wait a
minute I'm selling this for somebody
else yeah why am I not selling this for
myself and you're having to kind of
castrate your content in that sense you
know like at the risk of being
inauthentic which i think is is arguably
way worse like when you start right like
so we're selling out for the sake of
advertising like yeah yeah yeah you know
I think there's we we talked a lot about
YouTube on this podcast because a lot of
the people you know who we have as
guests are heavily related to youtube
and have history with it and or door
cast and sometimes yeah but you know I
frequently question you know how like
relatable are these stories so to speak
you know like it you know where either
influencers or filmmakers to a degree
content creators maybe is the best way
to put it mm-hmm
and now not everyone necessarily goes
out doing this stuff you know it's a
very small percentage but when I think
about that relatability and we start to
look at you know a lot of these other I
guess jobs and the way the economy
shifted shifted over the last few years
I think sure like it's way more
relatable than when than ever right now
because effectively we're seeing the
same thing happen that we saw on YouTube
happen with yeah we were in the post
mates delivery services any any app that
basically allows you to basically get
money get or get a gig or get a job
really quickly yeah you know and in
YouTube is basically the same version of
that it's kind of almost in a way was a
precursor to it except the I would say
the big difference between YouTube and
uber for that's what that matters you
know YouTube is scalable you know it's
not like you can trick your
car and driving Bullock the mile at this
one you can trick a viewer into watching
three times the views so to speak the
right tactics what if you had us it's
the same it's the same exact concept
though where you're tapping it you're
basically giving yourself up to like an
algorithm effective yeah yes a and this
like is kind of just like Network
effectively to try and earn your revenue
right and anyone can do it I mean I
guess I don't know if you can do this on
uber or not but a way that you could
scales if you owned multiple vehicles
you could lend them out to people who
don't own a vehicle who would just have
a driver so that's a concern for
self-driving cars is yeah that people
are just gonna buy up fleets at home and
right over
yeah right but I mean you can't trick
your passenger into riding three X miles
no but you're right in the sense that
it's like it's a gig it's a gig economy
it's never saying yeah exactly
oh I love that that reminds me of the
might go on a ramp but it Takashi's 6-9
6-9 Kanye song like Kanye is like oh my
gosh she's Instagram famous but she
can't keep a job yeah you're right that
that that's the whole thing that bleeds
back into the whole disconnect that
people feel when they go to the grocery
store or the go you go to Walmart and
you're buying that thing and you're like
what is this there I have no it might be
perfect for me but I have no feeling
towards it whatsoever
yeah and so at the end of the day that's
why you find yourself going back and
watching certain people and buying
certain products because you you want
you that's what you want you and you
want to support other people that are
doing that with your purchasing choices
and you know yeah they sleep it jojje in
X and Z or there's spending more money
on experiences than possessions and
things along those lines too which is
kind of interesting
you know like traveling and and stuff
like the hostess they have nowhere to
put the position
also like yeah I mean that gets him down
a whole nother road but the like the
future of ownership I think is gonna
change quite a bit over the next yeah
your generation well I think yeah kind
of all this stuff kind of plays into
that a little bit it does it very much
so does you buy subscription
yeah no now in this case it would come
as a subscription but like traditionally
you know because traditionally it would
cost you less to buy a subscription of
coffee than to own a coffee company
great yeah but when it comes to
something like your car your home
traditionally people were buying those
things and that's that's gonna continue
to change yeah wait a bit I think
they'll always be they'll always be a
market for ownership but yeah I don't
know as much if that's gonna that's
gonna remain yeah that it's like it's
basically Airbnb probably working on
that right now right it's like air B&B
long term basically an apartment just
hit a button we're getting to that Fight
Club moment yeah it's like I was like
reducing all the things that you you
possess in life to keep from it owning
you there's already a car rental company
that you can do that with a car rental
app yeah and were you and there's also
like car rental apps where you can well
you rent them to you it's like Airbnb
for your car mm-hmm I know we will we
use someone similar called relay rides
well I think I think they're back now
but they were dinner on their eyes okay
well I don't remember what sounds like a
Qi aroma it was open for like a years
like this app is hiding drugs and
I mean I be totally honest like we
wanted a Porsche on on it and like GTA
yeah so we go and yeah as lady she gives
me the keys he's like alright don't
think do anything stupid with it and I
yeah no not like we messed the car up by
any means yeah you know it's no more
damaged than driving enough don't worry
a statute of limitations is passed I
know I know but but but you know it's
it's it's weird yeah no I get it and
that's that I mean that and that drives
up the value of it though - yeah yeah
so I mean with a similar thing that
we're doing at least product product
wise is this book so I I hope it does
well I hope people actually enjoy it
it's not as consumable it's not as no
it's not a it's not a granola bar that's
for sure
but it broadens the demographic though
like people who may appreciate that yeah
it was looking at the cover of it and
everything's a no this is awesome
yes is awesome thanks I hope if we just
if we can find the 5% of people that
enjoy it that don't know who we are I
think it's a success
yeah and then you know what's what's
crazy is like I love them you know I
mean you get a lot of people out there
that are just haters and trolls and
whatnot but I think that the the the
core of what we do and you guys and
everyone else is like you can see it in
the content that you create right where
it's like you never try to phone it in
yeah it's not like you're trying to dupe
anybody over with clickbait or yeah a
compromise story or post-production or
anything like that we just want to do
more we want to do better you know it's
all right like help us help us help
everyone you know in this process and
you know there are unfortunate people
who do exploit that that situation and
stuff like that but that's what I'm
gonna see in the book and everything I'm
like oh this is this is a great value
proposition like think this is this is
exciting this is really cool I'm glad to
see that you guys did that yeah I mean
it's the only thing outside of just like
getting into game design itself right
now that can take what we're doing like
our strengths and create a product out
of it because I mean I don't know if
it's a if it really is a rule but I've
kind of said it a rule for myself though
which is that like video content has no
value and the value has to come from
whatever surrounds it so to speak
mmm and that mostly just stems from the
way I've seen YouTube as an ad based
system and like even Netflix is a
subscription-based system and just how
content in general has shaped itself
over the last few years where it's like
okay yeah the content itself has got to
be free if it's if it's a rectangle and
it's moving you know just let it be free
and then find another way well seriously
because I just feel like especially in
our space with you know our our audience
too and we've we've kind of established
that rule you know in a sense where it's
like yeah no absolutely absolutely I
don't know if it's the same way for
everyone else but at this point yeah
like we're we're kind of beholden to it
it would be I think it would be
exponentially foolish to go well we
really want people to pay for our
content so let's diverge go down an
entirely new section of the industry say
TV or movies and try to get someone to
pay for that and yeah all everything
we've built on hold it's like why
wouldn't we just take everything we've
built and expand upon it in a new
direction
that's super creative super fulfilling
and way more fun yeah yeah I think you
guys would really kill something in
using like the AR kit or something along
those lines like the augmented reality
yeah well we have some buddies over at
Google actually it's funny you mention
that yeah ours we're gonna be we're
gonna be messing with that pretty
shortly here ha see yeah there's some
incredible stuff out there right now
well it's funny cuz wouldn't like I'd
I'd started programming like 2006 when I
the iPhone came out as I got home this
is gonna be epic this is gonna be epic
so the the iOS SDK was surprisingly
pretty easy like I taught myself near
C++ and you know and Java and everything
but then using the the Apple SDK was
really easy and some of these AR kits
are just getting really good
really I mean especially if you worked
partnered with a firm or something like
that I'm sure you guys would just have a
homerun
yeah well it's like you can basically
you know what you can roll footage with
this stuff at this point it's all three
tracked you can throw in 3d models in
real time like you normally have they're
like rotoscope someone but it can just
do depth mattes like on the fly in real
time and basically it does like these
apps can do like almost 90% of the work
that we sit here cranking on it at
perfect in real time yeah it's insane
and so like I'm just sitting here going
like like dude the moments exists like
we everything we do is going to
transform like we're not gonna be on the
computers for like it is long anymore
and what was the 360 camera that they
sent us the other day where you can
basically throw it across the room oh
yeah crack the entire room it's not 360
it's not 360 okay but it's just it's
just a it's a phone camera yeah uses the
processor yeah yeah do everything else
easy you know you can take it just like
this and just go right across the room
yeah you know map it yeah exactly
because it's not just using image based
tracking anymore it's using like all the
sensors and accelerometers and IMU
inside the phone to make the data now so
I know it's like well this is filmmaking
the endgame of filmmaking you know like
this is like you just pretty much throw
the camera across the room and then some
stuff in and put in photo in also you
don't need a doctor I don't need lenses
anymore because if you have that depth
layer so to speak you can just go like
that's gonna be out of focus and then it
does that by yeah it's interesting
though because you still have to have
that understanding of it which is which
is fascinating right yeah well the
understanding it's like it's what's the
easiest in the hardest part right so
depends depends on what angle you come
at it from yeah it's only part of it
because I feel like even that like you
know like 3d s or cinema 4d and stuff
like that I think a lot of people right
I think a lot of people with yeah that's
funny a lot of people they they can they
begin in those situations and then the
world's our oyster and then they're
overwhelmed by possibilities and they
just really don't execute it the way
that it could be done and whereas if
you're
limited in the real space is like okay I
may use this lens and I'm gonna like
compress the image this way or with like
this or you use this focal length or
whatever as like well now you have every
opportunity but do you really understand
artistically why you want to do
something or how you're gonna achieve
that right that's where the artist
artistry comes in yeah you know and that
that you can't no machine listen here
machines well none of you will ever be
able to do that algorithmically figure
out what statistically most people like
and then they'll do that implement that
it doesn't make it creepy version of it
yeah I'll take all the videos that that
your that it's de monetizing for you and
just make like a like a more safe for
work version and then re-upload it I did
that in a video like I took and I like I
took gonna put like minecraft bows and
arrows on like the 50 Cal and everything
so like in slow-mo when the bullets like
leaving it's like a Minecraft arrow that
work I I mean it's still monetized right
now so it worked
I guess Wow Wow so Richard what's what's
next for you man what are you gonna blow
up next what are you gonna make next
what it was oh I have no idea I don't
know if I really want to talk about I
have a couple of projects one is easily
the most requested video I've ever had
like in 10 years it's like at least one
one comment and what's that come on it's
the most I mean so I'm making it doesn't
mean you just by mentioning it doesn't
mean you have to make I just don't want
anybody else to really like start
focusing let's say that like Mythbusters
attempted it at one time and so I was
gonna you know talk because I was part
of that discovery family for a while
it's gonna see if Tory maybe want to
come out and be a part of that video or
something along those lines but it's
it's one of those things where it's it's
like it's it's a lot of math it's a lot
of math and the margin for error is like
like it's gonna require a bunch of
collapsible circuit
you know measuring out to the grain of
powder and ballistics and stuff like
that I was like some minecraft
is it how to cobble it yeah so you know
is it it's one of those things where
it's gonna require a couple weeks of
dedication and just testing and things
along those lines and I just really
haven't had that so I don't want to
throw it out into the universe until I'm
committed to it don't bring it up then
what was the last math heavy that math
heavy video you shot math heavy you know
I don't know I mean I did some stuff
were four black rifle one of the videos
I wanted to do for a long time was
taking a 20 millimeter vulcan from an
f-16 and mounting it to a prius and a
set matt Niven down as I came in like I
don't know how much this is gonna cost
but it's gonna be around X is this
something that we could do for the
coffee company like yeah sure hey cool
it took like seven or eight months to
like you to do and everything and there
was a lot of m-theory moments where
we're like trying to figure out are
these electronic primers gonna actually
go you just did this
yeah just did it and and in September
and then created a series of videos with
it but the but this is all leading up to
something else and that that was one of
the key components right where it's like
I have to make sure that these
electronic primers because the
ballistics formula that I need to be
able to do what it is that I'm working
on I need to have such a a precise
munition going through the air that the
the delay of a mechanical firing pin
triggering or initiating that protect
I'll is too much of a variation so
having electronic primers so electricity
whenever another round puncture is a
collapsible circuit it fires immediately
yeah that's the kind of or or it has a
consistent delay that's the kind of
stuff that I needed and this was the
stuff I had to figure out in this whole
process
so can I stop you for one second yeah
and then keep going for those of you who
have no idea what Richard is talking
about he's talking about he's attempting
an experiment where the
delay time that occurs when a bullet
fires out of a traditional weapon is too
inconsistent for the experiment correct
okay
yeah because soon as soon as you start
getting into ballistics formulas be it
with explosives or projectiles like
bullets and things along those lines
look at it this way when the bullet
leaves a muzzle of a rifle or a weapon
system or something along those lines a
lot of people think about the X and the
y-axis right you so you have your your
you're up and you're down on a flat
sheet of paper but you also have a
z-axis which is the depth and so if you
take in you're off by just a fraction a
fraction of a millimeter on either the X
or the Y that translates to a lot
downrange on the z axis
that could be inches it could be feet it
could be hundreds of feet right so
depending on where you need to be
hitting target and things along those
lines you need exact like very very very
very consistent and very very precise
will you call us when you do that yeah
for sure okay yeah just down to take
part in that yeah okay sure yeah you
guys find yourselves out in Texas we'll
get you cowboy hat yeah so there's that
I mean I'm like for me I'm at this point
where you know I think you guys can kind
of relate where you know a lot of people
will ask what it what do you do like
what do you do and it's hard for me to
really sum it up in one sentence yeah
I'll tell you what I like to do like I
love analytics I love marketing but more
than anything I love storytelling I like
it a lot and I don't know where that's
gonna lead me but I love telling stories
either you know biographical fiction
whatever it is you know like here the
last year or two it's been telling
stories within black rifle coffee or
friends of them things all in those
lines before it was you know with rated
red and you know everything that we were
doing over there at Verizon you know
the stuff that I was doing before was
just kind of a means to an end that like
on full mag that's me being loud having
fun that's getting views it's you know
having fun it's it's honing skills with
slow motion I mean like I was saying
earlier it's like you know I did 10 or
15 videos in a day the quality is gonna
totally be compromised when you're
trying to do that much much much
quantity in such a short period of time
but I'm still refining skills and things
along those lines so that hopefully it
helps facilitate and storytelling down
the road for these things that I really
care about and I don't know where that's
gonna go over the next you know year or
so but I'm really really thankful really
feel really grateful that I've got
people that are willing to enjoy this
kind of journey that I go on and things
along those lines so we'll see where it
goes and you know working on some stuff
right now with some some dogs and things
along those lines because that's always
been a big part of who I am and what not
so we'll see as my travels go and where
those kind of creative inspirations come
from yeah man yeah and spend
inspirational to I mean you know because
you've been we've been working together
for for I mean as far back as like The
Immortals parody singing your apartment
and you guys shot auto rifles with him
like way back in the day so it's just
been inspirational any of that afro yeah
that's all fell out like like it's so
funny like I went to the drop zone and
it's probably been a couple of years but
there's still people there that work
there that I haven't seen in a long time
and they look so much older so much
older and I'm like wait have I aged that
much do I look at I maybe I should look
in the mirror I don't really that much I
got gray coming in though I got that in
a big way it's so funny when we start
looking at it's like oh [ __ ] man like
like YouTube was like like like content
creation like what I was doing with like
totally sketch and everything was
probably 2008 or 2009 it's like yeah 11
years ago my greatest fear is that I'm
gonna bling
and I'm gonna be like an old man with a
cane and a Mario see ya
making clickbait like gamer videos a man
while you're enjoying it right the other
thing is that I've been really like you
know looking at these different things
and trying to soak it up and enjoying
the ride and everything that's one
reason why I wanted to stop by here's
like man like you know like life's way
too short not like have have good times
yeah exactly
see that's the thing it's like you know
everyone you know in the back of their
minds you know they're all it's it's
great reaching for the stars and aiming
but it's also really easy to like forget
to look down and realize that you know
maybe you were in a situation you do
enjoy so yeah it's funny it went so I
live down the road here when I first
moved to Los Angeles probably I was like
2004-2005 yeah and this is before the LA
Live project and MacArthur Park was
known for being a fairly rough area and
everything and I lived in this this
house and he was a perceptional II like
rough neighborhood and I remember I
remember I you know that my days didn't
really fill up with a lot and just like
the community aspect and you know I
guess maybe it was a gang territory and
whatnot but the community like like all
of us would hang out on the weekends we
grill asada and stuff like that I
remember I wrote it tilled up the front
yard and planted corn and then
rototilled up the back yard planted okra
and I'm like so the neighbors would be
like it's like you know it was like
these these little things that really
are nothing but you know the things that
you remember down the road and
everything is like yeah like like us
playing airsoft and stuff like that yeah
there's like so much fun it's like okay
here's the workweek okay it's like
Saturday or Sunday let's all right let's
go play airsoft or something like that
all the time bro yeah now you can't
afford to get injured no we play more we
just do it in the building now yeah
just do point-blank remember remember uh
like we we went to tempest free-run in
Academy mm-hmm and everybody started
giving yeah totally screwed up his leg
and then it was just like he's unable to
be active is is like yeah I don't think
it's ever gonna feel right again and I'm
like wow that's really sad you just
moved to LA you're like that was a great
time it was just funny watching everyone
try and get into parkour
it's like parkour was big back there in
2011 you know it's like I mean I can
jump over that box Wow don't you kid
it's so funny everybody's like doing
flips and like they're jumping over
things and then there's Richard in the
back he's just like running up the wall
cuz he's tall like just run and do the
like bull foot thing is on the walls
grab keep doing the flip thing that's
fun it's fun it's cool and doing a great
job yeah I parked forward up this ladder
it's good yeah yeah no not me that mean
yeah that's great well man thanks for
coming on and yeah appreciate your
opinions your views and everything no
and I wish you guys the best of luck and
and everything you're doing thanks for
having me I appreciate it yeah we'll see
you in Austin in a little while here
[ __ ] yeah bring it bring it
alright well that was a great episode
thank you Richard for coming on the
podcast and hanging out with us man it
was great catching up with you was great
talking to you and it's great learning a
little bit more about the well basically
your crazy life and don't forget today's
episode is sponsored by top 10 games you
can play in your head by yourself this
book is available on Amazon right now
you can find it by going to our website
corridor digital calm and just click in
the link it'll be at the top of the page
can't miss it anyway
enjoy because this is things get crazy
in this book